الارجنتيني ميسي يحسم الجدل بشان مشاركته
في المونديال المقبل عام 2026 طبعا قبل
مباراه منتخب بلاده هي الوديه امام
استراليا كذا ان كاس العالم في 2022 على
الارجح كانت مشاركته الخامسه والاخيره حسب
ما نشرته صحيفه
وقد يشارك في بطوله كوبا امريكا المقبله
لكن بشكل مبدئي لا يفكر في تمثيل التانجو
في النسخه المقبله من اكبر بطولات كره
القدم طبعا حقق لقب المونديال خلال نسختي
قطر الاخيره ليضيف النجمه الثالثه للمنتخب
اللاتيني ولتكون مسك الختام لمسيره لن
تتكرر بسهوله ميسي اعتقد عمره 33 هلا
تقريبا 3
يعني خلاص موعد
يعني كان في حديث انه اعلن اعلن بانه
مشاركته في قطر وحصول على كاس العالم هي
قد تكون المشتركه الاخيره لكن مشاركته في
كوبا امريكا قد يريد من خلالها الفوز ايضا
بهذا الكاس وبالتالي يختم
بالقمه يعني لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات